good morning everyone
welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baylor district council cabinet and
mid-suffolk district council cabinet i
am councillor john ward leader of baby
district council and also in attendance
is councillor gerard brewster deputy
leader of mid-south district council we
will be joined jointly chairing the
meeting today however for reasons of
efficiency i will be leading the items
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so
and that you use to hand sanitize and
wipes provided please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off and
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'll now move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
yes chair we have received apologies
from councillor morley council flatman
and councillor fleming
thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members are there any to declare
councilor brewster thank you chair um
yes a non-binary interest on the gateway
14 item
as chair of the holding company thank
you
we've got some others
oh sorry
council gold
thank you very much uh also uh
non-pecuniary interests with gateway 14
item as a director of the holding camp
thank you thank you whitehead
same for myself i'm a director of
gateway 14.
thank you
right for no others then item three
which is paper bca2122 to confirm the
minutes of the baba cabinet meeting held
on the 6th of september 2021.
uh these start on page 5 of your
agenda pack i won't go through each page
individually but are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
from only the baby members
no
okay they may have a proposal please
kasirathi secondary council osborne
thank you
i'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
councilman crawl may i take your vote
please
and council davis please may take your
vote
thank you
council possibility
thank you chad that's unanimous thank
you
i'll now hand over to councillor
brewster
um
to confirm the minutes
of the mid-socket cabinet meeting held
on the 6th of september 2021
which you can find on the first i page
of item five uh sorry on page five
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
[Music]
um and could i have a proposal please
counselor headingham
and the second to please councillor
gould
the gov governance officer will now
conduct contact vote
thank you chair members the vote are now
in progress on your app
do
counselor burn
thank you
chair that is six vote for that's
unanimous
thank you
right moving on then item four to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the castle's petition
scheme
none received thank you
item five questions by counsellors
none received
thank you
and item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
chair we have received no such matter
referred thank you
item seven
members forthcoming decisions list does
anyone have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list as it's
currently
printed
no
okay great and we'll move on to item
eight which is paper bca2123
and mca 2121 which is the civil parking
enforcement that's the off street
parking enforcement annual report for
2020 to 2021
and firstly i'll invite the baby cabinet
member for the environment
to
introduce the report
councilmember vici
thank you very much chair
i'm very pleased to be able to bring to
cabinet the first annual report of the
civil parking enforcement off street
cpe had no sooner started in our
districts than covet hitters
for those who don't remember cpe started
on the 6th of april 2020 and this
provide and this report provides you
with information regarding the
performance of cpe this past fiscal year
although the report is primarily for
noting it is also recommended that you
agree to such a report being produced
annually going forward by taking this
decision then bdc through the cabinet is
providing a vehicle for members
and the public to be kept informed of
the performance of cpe
the purpose of cpe is to ensure that
traffic regulation orders in baba
district council car parks are adhered
to
baba district council entered into a
partnership with west suffolk and
ipswich in order to to deliver the
service
and during most of 2020 we decided that
we would cease parking charges in bdc
car parks yet the enforcement teams
continued to provide a service
i draw your attention to the finance
section of appendix a
where you will see that the penalty
charges only amounted to 43 of the
overall cost but one has to remember
that we were not charging for the first
quarter of 2020
one
we'll see what this year brings without
the startup costs
in appendix a you will see a breakdown
of the performance for all our car parks
which i find interesting reading
i very much hope that you will agree
with me that this informative report
should be produced annually
any surplus income generated after all
costs are paid will be used to help
support the cost of running this parking
service thank you very much
thank you councillor
i'll now invite the mid-suffolk cabinet
member to introduce the mid-sofa report
thank you
i'm very pleased to be able to bring to
cabinet on behalf of council fleming the
first annual report of civil parking
enforcement off street
cpe came into force on the 6th of april
2020.
as you all know that this was during a
co-vid lockdown and so enforcement
started later in june
this report provides you with
information regarding the performance of
cpe this past fiscal year
the purpose of cpe for mid-suffolk is to
ensure that car park traffic regulation
orders are adhered to we plan to make
this an annual report so that we can
share with the pub with the public
information and statistics about the
enforcement function and keep people
informed
mid suffolk district council entered
into a partnership with west suffolk and
ipswich in order to deliver this service
within the report you can see a
breakdown of the cost for cpe as well as
the income received through penalty
charge notices given
in future years any surplus in income
generated after all costs are paid will
be used to help support the cost of
running this parking service thank you
thank you council helling him um may i
have a seconder from mid suffolk and
then i'll ask for a second from babel
which i forgot to do a few minutes ago
thank you
um
council richardson and uh secondary from
baby castle osborne thank you
so firstly do we have any questions from
baber members
council hold
yeah a couple of questions um
mill lane car parks on that list and
it's under on the understanding that
bill lane will become a permit holder
car park in the future
will that be within the next 12 months
and if so we can then use the 116 visits
in other locations to make it more cost
effective that's one question
will we be looking at the
to increase or decrease certain visits
to car parks depending on what sort of
penalties we're finding in those car
parks
the cost of the district is still
reasonably high at forty five thousand
pounds so
as this was started and covered year do
we expect
that to fall
and last but not least the market hill
in sudbury which is a county-owned car
park who actually controls the parking
on there
four questions sorry four questions uh
cass would you
like to pick up on those to start with
please
thank you very much chair
thank you council a lot for the question
so um in terms of mill lane and the
residence parking uh proposal there
officers are working at the moment to
get ready to make some changes to the
traffic regulation order which includes
the statutory consultation with
residents around the area so we're just
putting that plan into place at the
moment and shortly we'll be going out to
consultation with residents to see if
they support that
car park moving to residence parking
permits only
i'm afraid i'm going to have to ask you
to repeat a couple of those because they
were quite quick but the latter one i
know was about um
who owns that or runs that car park it's
suffolk county council and they have a
um
service level agreement with ipswich to
enforce so it's a suffolk county council
run
on street car park so the different
officers that enforce the parking on the
market will compare to our own officers
that come from west suffolk
so they will they will probably share
stuff i would say so they're not sending
two different lots of officers out so um
the we pay for a percentage of um
people
ftes full-time equivalents i guess um
that go out and enforce and then suffolk
county council use the same team
um but obviously add some additional
offices to it to do the on-street
enforcement so
we don't have people going to do off
street and leaving and coming back to do
on stream we just want to make sure we
won't pay for their parking we're
certainly not paying for it that's for
sure the other question was um the cost
is quite still reasonably high to the
district
um do we think that
the current or the past year the figures
were affected by covid i'm not saying we
want to find people but
it was a cost that i think a lot of us
didn't think we would be looking at in
this financial year so
do we anticipate that coming down
and
the other point was will we be looking
at targeting different car parks after
gathering a year's data to perhaps
reduce visits or increase visitors in
other car parks
lovely thank you so um we
had around a quarter of the first
financial year that wasn't enforced to
the normal standards
we also stopped
charging in those periods as well so
there was not very much to enforce even
if we'd carried on and so there was a
definite deficit there that we would
probably see an increase for in the
first quarter of the next financial year
what i'd also say is there continue to
be further um social distancing mothers
measures and lockdown measures during
the year so again as people start going
back to work as people start going back
to shop and eat out then we're going to
see a increase in parking usage and
therefore unfortunately an increase in
and bad parking behaviour so you are
likely to get an increased amount of
fixed penalty notice oh penalty charge
notices
then using this data what we have been
able to see is where there are less
penalty charges notices given
and what we can do is use that
information to send civil enforcement
officers to car parks where
there's a greater need for enforcement
so absolutely we can do that on an
annual basis
and move that
that resource around as we need it
thank
you you cass any other questions from
baber
council busby
yeah thank you as the any information on
on street parking
when will we get that
thank you councillor busby so suffolk
county council obviously look after on
the street and at the moment they don't
publish an annual report i have spoken
to them to find out if we could get some
information from them however
it won't be in the same format but i can
certainly share with you um
the the same kind of information in
terms of
penalty charge notices given and the
areas that they're given in all of that
information will be available through a
free different information request from
a member of the public so um i can
certainly ask suffolk if they could
share that with us
thank you be useful to have that once a
year as well just the number of visits
they make and the number of uh penalty
charge notices they issue out thanks
yeah i think uh i would agree with that
particularly with um some of the the
on-street parking where it directly
affects um baba and baba residents
particularly for instance down at the
stratfor denim
boundary at the store where where the
new yellow lines and restrictions have
been put in place
i have a quick question myself and that
is on the hadley
railway walk car park
do we not patrol that
so there's no traffic regulation orders
on the hadley car park and so there's
nothing that a civil enforcement officer
could enforce there we do however have
public realm officers that go there to
check and inspect the area but there's
no enforcement possible there
thank you
any more questions from from beaver
if not
mitt suffer do you have any questions
council whitehead
oh thank you
and clearly this is the first year's
data which is sort of
affected by covid but i'm just looking
at the um car parking in eye i guess it
takes the guys sort of hours round trip
to get up there
and um we see buckhorn lane car park
three patrol visits a total of zero
hours and one minute so they're spending
20 seconds in the car park and i
understand his 24-hour maximum stay free
car parking so i just wonder what the
efficacy of that is
so we were keen for any
car park with the traffic regulation
order to have um
visits there clearly
when the traffic regulation orders don't
have much for this civil enforcement
officers to be able to enforce um we're
going to look at as i said with weber
actually to change those resources
around we can look to increase or
decrease resources on an annual basis or
we could look to push that resource into
other car parks where there's a higher
number of enforcement needed
in which case um other members are
councillor field and then uh castle
wilhelm
thank you just a couple of points uh
firstly just about the thought that we
do need an on-street car parking report
i mean
many of the uh
areas like needham um
need a marketing substantial on street
parking as does places like clayton so
there's certainly a great interest to
people
um the the question really the
expenditure of uh 85
000 pounds essentially
and that yielded 19 000 pounds of
penalty
charge
which are obviously low due to
covert but i just wondered you did quote
um
that the previous year we received
something like 8 000 pounds of penalty
charges
and wondered what the expenditure to
gain those was in other words really
what's happened to our cost of policing
car parks
thank you councillor field so
i wanted to put a comparison in there
the change that cpe brought for us so we
there was a
recognition from mid-suffolk that the
amount of enforcement that happened
previously in car parks was very little
it was quite low there was around one
fte that went out and to enforce car
parks so with the introduction of cpe uh
mid-suffolk have taken the opportunity
to increase the amount of patrols that
go on so the breakdown of this
expenditure includes a number of ftes
some
cars phones uniform and radios that kind
of thing so it's a combination of all of
that so it is an increased amount of
expenditure i can get the exact um
previous expenditure figure for you if
you'd like and but this was
recognised that we wanted a better
standard of enforcement as well
with the new cpe regulations
thank you cass castle
thank you chair yeah um
i've got three questions the first is a
rhetorical question would it be possible
for errors in the attached document to
be put right before it becomes more
public
for instance the footer is
civil parking enforcement off street
annual report 2021 2021.
i guess it's 20
20 20 to 21 but i mean is it it's a
document that the public might be
looking at
um so i think it would be it would be
good there are a few others there are
there's a there's a few um apostrophes
and commas sprayed around the place so
if they could be looked at i would be
grateful
i'm not sorry i didn't spot that one
myself
i just noticed it now though well it has
it has picked out who's read who's read
the document hasn't it anyway um
somebody as um
councillor whitehead said some visits
are very short and i picked up the ones
that were less than a minute
um
where is travel time taking into account
i mean the travel time to get to i to
spend 20 seconds there is significant
um
could that be i mean i'm not i'm not
asking the could it be looked at is is
there any point should we know how much
of the time that these these people are
working is in travel time because my
guess is it's quite significant quite
significant quite a lot of travel time
um but the real question is around the
asda car park
um it was without payment machines for a
while
um
so will visits
there need to be more frequent in the
coming sort of 12 months or so
other machines now working if we got a
permanent fix to them or are they
temporarily fixed and need replacing
thank you castle well i will pass over
to cass but the um uh the comment about
the machines
uh not not working and we've got a
similar problem in in babel with a
number of our machines no longer in
action and and i think that's purely
because of the age and the
the cost of um repairing we're waiting
for new ones aren't we
thank you so on the i question first of
all um that doesn't include travel time
and we can get travel time so all the
vehicles have trackers on them so we are
able to do that
what i would say however is we kind of
share that travel time with suffolk
because obviously they're enforcing the
on-street traffic regulation orders as
well so they're not just going up to the
car parks they're going to do all of the
enforcement however that doesn't detract
from the fact that there is a decent
amount of travel time absolutely so i'm
happy to get some figures for you on
that and yes in terms of the stock
market machines over at meadow centre
car park
we've had a few issues with their end of
life we unfortunately had some issues
with when um the
refurb was going on that a power line
was cut that happened just after a bad
spell but we are going through
procurement at the moment to get new
machines for that car park so we hope
within the next couple of months that
they'll be in and then we can get some
uh get them installed
the chair if i may does that mean that
they the the number of visits and the
length of visits to what i call the asda
car park
will will be different from the last 12
months
so they'll be different to points in the
last 12 months so obviously there's been
quite a lot of time where the machines
have been working and then there is a
decent amount of enforcement going on at
that point when there's uh less to
enforce so parking within a bay for
instance is one thing that can be
enforced if someone's parked badly
across a couple of bays that that could
get a ticket and so yes there will be
times where there's been less
enforcement it will return to the normal
level of enforcement
thanks guys council mclaren
thank you chair um
i just tried trying to get to the bottom
of this uh
why
we're actually doing this is the purpose
to change parking behavior
um or is it to uh try and nail all the
transgression transgressors that we can
what is the
with the teams that go out what are they
trying to do actually thank you joe
yes
that's a great question that i'm very
happy to answer because actually they're
about changing behavior so the point of
enforcement is to tell to show someone
with a bit more of a stick that they're
doing something wrong and to encourage
them to change their behavior
so actually
the end result what you'd like is no
enforcement office is necessary because
everybody's behaving properly
unfortunately that's simply not the case
but what you will get to hopefully after
a period of enforcement is less people
doing it so you will see the costs
staying static and the income reducing
and can i just follow that um but of
course the thing casts with car parking
is that it's not necessarily the same
people coming back time and time we have
a lot of tourists a lot of visitors
who perhaps misunderstand the rules that
we've got so it that is a very difficult
thing to achieve thank you
okay um
castle busby
uh well we're about to go into debate
but is this the question before debate
or waiting
sorry
okay um well before we move into debate
council osborne did you have another
question or was that a game for debate
okay
right if there are no more questions
then we will now move into debate
firstly um baba members and certainly
custer osborne and then castle busby
um thank you mr chairman um obviously um
listening to the conversation that we've
been having over the through the
question time it's apparent that there
is a desire for there to be a on-street
report as well
and i completely concur with that so as
the seconder of the recommendation i
would like to make a third
recommendation
that a civil parking enforcement
on-street report be produced annually
yes is that possible to add that as a
third recommendation
i'm not entirely sure so i'm not the
owner of the information so what i can
do is request the information and share
it without a doubt i'm not entirely sure
i can write a report on behalf of
suffolk county council to publish that
information what i could do is bring it
as part of the annual report within the
text of the body of the report when we
present each annual cpa report off the
street
could the wording be then that we
request
an annual report rather than a report be
produced yes of course thank
you you charles roswell council busby
yeah and i think it's important if you
said that the the purpose of this is to
change behavior well really we're not
interested in people that park across
two bays particularly or perhaps stay an
extra 15 minutes in the car park when
they shouldn't have done i mean that's
just about extracting funds out of them
the key if we want to change behavior
are those people that park in
inconsiderate places on the road and
there are many areas around the district
where that's happening and the
the residents of those areas were very
keen to see
the
control of this parking pass to the
districts because the police hadn't got
the time to do anything about it and
they were relying on this move
solving their problems so that's why i
think it's important that we get this
on street parking
thank you councillor busby um
i would take issue partly with with what
you've said now i do do appreciate and i
do understand that the on street parking
is a significant problem and we do need
to to make sure that we we address the
um the problems inconsiderate on street
parking calls but uh behavioral change
is most definitely
one of the aspirations because if people
overstay
it means that
the churn is reduced and it is churn
that we want to encourage um in order to
make uh best use of the spaces that we
have available and that was one of the
primary uh drivers to be honest of uh
changing the um the short-term parking
tariffs it's all about
encouraging churn encouraging more
visitors encouraging better football for
our businesses admittedly um that that's
not um fully appreciated by um a number
of uh people in our communities and and
uh
they argue against that but um that that
is one of the principal drivers of of
changing the the short-term tariffs as
as it is a driver of having um
enforcement in our car parks our street
enforcement
uh councillor davidson councilman mccraw
yeah thanks um i agree
with you council award about the
problems within the car parks and we
need to address that but definitely the
on-street parking needs to be looked at
as well and soviet county council really
do need
to um
to send a report because some of the
practices
that it appears that
they're not dealing with
for example charging people that are in
disabled base when there's no clear
marking that it's a disabled bait that's
an example
but for us we need to also i think up
our game you mentioned earlier on about
the uh car parking ticketing machines
not working correctly and you just got
to look at the amount of appeals
um
you know 43 have been successful in in
appealing against uh the cpe uh action
and goodness knows how many others just
can't be bothered so you know we need to
do our bit as well to help the residents
and that's a comment not a question
that's a very good point yeah we must
make sure we have fully functioning
machines and that people can
use those and also have more than one
fully functioning machine in the car
park so they don't have to walk from one
end of the car park to the other
sometimes at night time when it's dark
council mccraw and then castle navisi
thank you chair
um i think it's important as a
counterpoint to the conversation
discussion we're having
on on street parking that we do
distinguish the difference between on
street and off street that has been a
constant problem at any discussion of
this it's quite clear to me that many
members of the public don't appreciate
that distinction when they talk about
parking they talk about parking and they
mean the parking that annoys them which
is largely on street and that
distinction that it is not within our
gifts to control
on street parking is not one that's
clearly understood and i think we need
to make it clear now we can make all the
representations we want
to suffer county council but if they
choose
not to follow suit
then i don't think there's a great deal
we can do
we can apply pressure
and the other point i was going to raise
is that the government have been
considering uh possibilities of
those people who park on verges and
putting giving powers to various
councils
i don't know what level those powers are
being considered for whether it be
county or district
they're not the subject i think of
parking orders as we've been discussing
but whichever one those are i think we
need to continue to press government
this is some this is not
on-road
and it's not off-road
it's on verges it's on pavements it's
obstructing people in daily lives and
obviously it's also you know it's
causing problems with deliveries and all
sorts of things so i think we need to
distinguish between these three things
on off and verge
and there are lots of cases i'm sure
every community has places where the
verges are parked on
i think we need to distinguish them and
i think the report needs to make that
distinction when it comes back because i
don't think the message is getting
through
thank you council certainly the
on-street parking is is uh enforcement
is improving there are more patrols so
um and uh
a greater uh part of our district is
getting patrolled now um for on street
parking which which is good but
um cass do you have any um update on
council mccraw's
uh comments about
pavement and verge parking and whether
we're likely to get similar powers in in
the near future and um whether those
powers would
would be within our gift or counties or
how how it would be implemented
so i think the the answer is it's
probably going to be a bit of both so at
the moment we haven't heard anything for
some time in terms of those powers
changing but where a traffic regulation
order is in in place um
that affects both the road and the verge
so essentially a traffic regulation
order covers from boundary to boundary
so someone's head your fence to the next
person's head your fence so that's
footpath verge
road and then foot pathway to the other
side as well so if someone if there were
double yellows there for instance if
someone was parked on the verge they
could get a ticket for parking on double
yellows
so if
the cpu powers were changed to allow um
verge parking
outside of where there's a traffic
regulation order then that would be the
new the new bit what i'm hoping there
for is that where we own the land for
instance or perhaps parish or town
councils that we can introduce bylaw
where we could still end up we could
still do some kind of enforcement
thank you uh
yes okay yes my only concern is that the
traffic regulation orders that exist for
the most part are very very limited and
and they look likely to remain so um
obviously anywhere there is a patch of
grass that is convenient somebody's
going to park on it and double yellow
lines regardless
yeah we'll have to
pick that up at some point in the future
but a good point council malvisi
thank you chair um
coming back to
councillor davis's remark um
disabled bays
are marked out in our car parks although
not terribly boldly
however
the public can park on a double yellow
line
if they're disabled and they have a blue
badge and their timer disc
which an awful lot of people don't
appreciate
the other point made by council macro
the distinction is not clearly
understood absolutely
but i think that by having see
civil parking enforcement
actively
enforcing
will slowly but surely educate people on
what they can and cannot do
um
okay
thank you thank you guys uh castle holt
yeah i think see cpe is is is a small
step in what our ambition is which is
really to bring the strategic park and
review forward
um
it's crucial
to our long-term ambition
to find the right balance i think
for our residents and our businesses
and on high streets
just cpe doesn't solve a problem
the strategic parking review when
completed
in itself
won't
solve a problem if we just push cars to
another area
we have to accept the number of cars
we've got
in our districts
and they need to park somewhere
historically our planning system i feel
has let us down and government has let
us down
in what we're able to achieve through
the planning team
the parking
is insufficient on most estates
not alone let alone for the residents
but also for visitors
so it's not
an easy thing to solve and it's cp isn't
going to solve that and nora is just
saying off street parking that's
bringing rules and regulations
to stop people parking on verges or
parking on pavements which the
government has mentioned
because all it's going to do is push the
problem somewhere else into another
street into another area what we need to
understand and recognize is we have this
number of vehicles on the road they need
to park somewhere and we have to find
the facilities for them to park in the
areas for them to park so cp is a small
function of that it's a good step
forward but we've got a lot more to do
in solving the problems that we all face
in our villages towns and districts
thank you council hall yeah
fully accept that point but we as part
of our strategic review of parking we've
got to make sure that um we understand
where that extra provision for parking
is going to be required and it's not
just car parks in town centres it is
residential areas as well where there is
insufficient parking
council movisi
thank you chair to come back to
councillor holt's
very valid comments
cpe is part of the equation
which is why we're looking at
sustainable travel alternatives
because we want people to use public
transport
cycle
into towns and to the center of villages
it's all part of
the recipe for a successful alternative
transport model
i'll just come back on that slightly um
a lot of government forecasts a lot of
independent forecasts predict there'll
be a 25 increase in motor vehicles on
the road whether it be electric or
whatever by 2050 so the car isn't going
away the car has to be
factored into anything that we look
forward to in the future and i agree
with councilwomazy that sustainable
transport has to be something we want to
encourage and try and provide but we
can't
let the fact that the motor vehicle is
here for a long time to stay and we have
to allow and build in and accommodate
those vehicles when we look at the
strategic parking view as well as
encouraging sustainable forms of
transport
thank you
okay i'll now move over to mid suffolk
any mid suffolk members wish to
enter the debate
nope
well then um i think then i'll ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote please
yes chair i have actually had the um
additional amended recommendations added
if you would just like to cast your eyes
over but make sure you agree
that i think that's fine yeah okay
members do vote is now in progress and
it's the simultaneous vote so um you
should be able to vote at the same time
chair that is eight votes for uh for
faber recommendations so that's
unanimous
thank you
sorry we had some technical problems and
the mid suffix work will now be started
sorry
do you apologize
chair and that is six votes four and
that is also unanimous thanks henry
right i will have a a very short break
to allow officers to
be seated for the next item um although
tom is anyone else is it just you
do we don't really need a break then do
we
okay
we'll um we'll proceed
then um
okay item nine paper bca 2124 and mca
2122 community infrastructure levy sill
expenditure program for october 2021 and
i'll now invite the baba cabinet member
for planning to introduce the baba
report
counselor arthi
thank you chairman um you will all be
familiar now with these reports
this time we have only one award
which is below ten thousand pounds so is
for noting only
it is for lavan prentice street car park
um and the ev power supply
it's
9999 pounds and 99p
which is around half of the the cost
with lavender paris council funding the
rest
this is all detailed at paragraph 4.1
i'm proposing the recommendations of
paragraph 3 which include endorsement of
the appendices
with appendix a
providing the updated position detailing
all of our seal awards thank you
chairman
thank you councillor may i have a second
from baba please
castle busby
i'll now invite the mid-suffolk cabinet
member for planning to introduce the
mid-suffolk report castle byrne
thank you chairman um
i'd like to introduce um paper mca 21-22
which is the report on the sill
expenditure program for october 2021
this report seeks to obtain approval by
cabinet for mid-soviet sill expenditure
program october 2021 which forms
appendix a to this report
short there are four bids for you today
all of the details of these bids are
contained within your papers
but i will briefly run through them
before moving the recommendation
bid m 21
hyphen
0 2 seeks
20
and 148 pounds
for the provision
of a wheeled sports area in wrecking
hall
mid m21 hyphen zero five six fifty nine
thousand nine hundred and ninety four
pounds
towards significant improvements to
debenham community center
bid m 21 hyphen zero eight
seeks eighteen thousand seven hundred
and eighty nine pounds twenty pence
towards new play equipment in framstone
and bid m21 hyphen zero six seeks
nineteen thousand five hundred and
ninety three pounds and eighty-one pence
towards improvements of the chamberlain
hall
in elmswell
the first three of those bids are to be
taken from the local infrastructure fund
with the last one
being proposed to be taken from the ring
fenced infrastructure fund for elmswell
i therefore move recommendations 3.1 and
3.2 in your report and i ask for a
seconder
i'm happy to take any questions you have
but it's likely that i'll fail them over
to tom parker who's here to support
any of the more technical queries that
you might have
thank you
thank you council byrne may i have a
second of mid suffolk councillor
richardson thank you
okay firstly um baby members are there
any questions on the weber report
okay mid suffolk members do you have any
questions on the mid-suffolk report
and
other councillors councillor field you
have your hand up
yes just really a brief point on it the
um
i note uh as always that uh bids are not
considered valid until they have a
have planning permission i was just
wondering whether there was a view on
whether that's discouraging um local
bodies from bidding
obviously it's a considerable
expenditure to make
before the point at which you know you
will be able to obtain funding for
whatever you're proposing
uh yes it is a a matter that i
understand has been considered by the
civil member working group um and it is
a requirement for all funding
applications to know that what they are
whether sale or to elsewhere it's kind
of inherent part of seeking funding that
funders have confidence that you can
deliver that which you are seeking
funding for
um and i think it's always been
important to the the member working
group that where seal money is allocated
that it doesn't sit allocated and
unspent for a number of years while kind
of aspirational projects may be worked
up further or such like
so i guess
it's possible that it's
restraining or constraining to people
but clearly the council can work with
those bodies and
councillors very effective communities
team who can work with local
organizations and
through our external funding officer or
through other funding officers can work
with them and and the council also as
the planning authority um provides
pre-application advice for example um at
a reduced rate to parish councils
um in order to kind of facilitate those
kind of conversations and we'll always
have kind of helpful and supportive
conversations about what is required to
make a planning application and for
often
seal items
you need to do the work anyway so if
you're improving your village hall and
you're improving it in a particular way
you need to do the work to understand
what the costs of that are is it
something that you can fund from your
own purse or do you need to go out is
still something that can wholly fund it
or do you need to go to other external
funders
um so
i i haven't we haven't had feedback and
we have heard from a number of parts of
our community who have spoken about
sealer scrutiny over
over the years since we adopted it and
we haven't had feedback that it is
off-putting to people
but it is something that we can raise
again within the member working group to
see whether it
needs revisiting but as yet
don't have any and that unless you're
bringing news that it is constraining
some of your local parishes or community
organizations and we can feed that in we
don't have any feedback that it's
proving
negative for people
thank you for that just comment i don't
have any specific
examples but clearly there is an issue
of raising planning permission
and getting quotations from work all the
things that as you say are absolutely
necessary to get a valid project moving
but but when taking
combination
uh they're probably uh trivial for a
bunch of mitsubishi officers but pretty
demanding for people out in the
community thank you
thank you council willem
thank you chair um it's a question about
the the number of um
uh inquiries that seem to be going
nowhere or may well go nowhere um
there's quite a few in from i town
council i just wondered whether um other
town councils parish councils and the
like
are submitting
significant numbers of um of inquiries
um and they and they seem to
be listed here when they're unlikely to
go anywhere unlikely to be a successful
bid i just wonder how how that happens
and is it peculiar to i or are other
stone market town council for instance
are they uh submitting um bids that are
going nowhere just getting a feel for
the the percentage of bids that seem to
be coming in or inquired about
that are going nowhere
council byrne or tom
tom
i'm happy to pick that up i think one
thing it shows you is is where you have
proactive town and parish councils who
are exploring what they can do to
improve the facilities available to
their communities there is quite a mixed
picture
across the area where some ward members
might be more proactive in encouraging
their town and parish councils to kind
of come forward with inquiries
some town and parish councils may seek
to kind of
hold back
until they're certain that something's
going to go ahead others like to kind of
have exploratory conversations quite
early on
um so there's quite a mixed picture and
i'm struggling
at the moment to give you a kind of
consistent yes there are these seven
parishes that are constantly making
enquiries and there are these 57 that
never get in touch with us um but i can
go away and look at it for you if you'd
like to explore a bit further but i
think it
my instinct is that it reflects the
different ways of working of
different parish clerks and
parish and town councils
thank you tom that's certainly a similar
experience in in beiber with um
different approaches and different
parishes and uh um how proactive the
clerks and the chairman are so
um councilman mclaren
thank you chair i'm actually
reinforcing what my two colleague
counsellors have raised
which is what doesn't get through or
initially
they don't even consider applying for
sale
i think that's one of my concerns the
and so we're back to
i'm asking the question about enabling
and empowering parish councils and
parish clerks
to get involved in this process i
i think there is some need not just
about a sill i've got to say i think
there are a lot of issues around
how efficient
parishes are and how motivated they are
so i don't know whether there's some
something we can do as a council to
some training or something
tom
are you able to provide anything tommy's
looking in my diary okay i think so
it's the casarathi i sit on the
working group i think there are some
fairly good points that have been made
there
we now offer a cill inquiry service
which we use not to do and we
specifically introduced that to
eliminate um the the likelihood or
reduce the likelihood rather
of lots of work being done by
groups on projects that we're going to
end up being ineligible um so i think
that's helped quite a lot so that people
can actually come to us first um and and
say to the sill team this is what we're
thinking about um you know how can we
fund it and we help with other sources
of funding as well because a lot of the
community projects are restricted if
they're larger projects to the 75 or 75
000 so we help with other funding
including our own community grants
program
a lot of groups
some parish councils and i have to say
some district councillors
don't fully understand the process
we have done some engagement events to
offer training
and i think yours is a is a very very
good point um the rules with regards to
seal do change um we we've updated our
framework and of course we've got a new
charging regime
which we've proposed so i absolutely
accept that as we move forward the need
to get out there to communities um
particularly paris councils but not only
parish councils because a lot of these
bids don't actually come from paris
councils they come from community groups
like village hall committees
and others
so
as as we move forward there is a
constant need to go out there update and
train um so that people are aware of
what's available
what they can and can't bid for and the
the point with regard to planning
permissions that was made earlier on i
think it's quite important to remember
that we should only be funding schemes
that are ready to go we expect delivery
of that infrastructure so we we want a
scheme that comes to us that's got full
consent
it's fully funded because we may not be
funding the whole lot so we want to know
what all of the other funding sources
are to make sure that the scheme can
actually be delivered so that's that's
quite important as well but i absolutely
accept the bit about training we need to
get out there and engage constantly
thank you for that response casarathy
tom did you want to say anything further
yeah just just to um supplement the the
response from councillor arthur was to
to
if um parishes or community groups are
focusing on
should i apply for sil they're asking
themselves the wrong question so the key
question and and um councillor davis is
perked up there so for
for all of our communities they should
be asking what is it that we want to do
within our community that can make it a
better place for our residents and once
they ask that question then they can get
in contact with us as the council and
you've got a a
kind of enlivened communities team over
recent months who are continually
growing their capacity
so
they should be getting in touch either
through you as ward council or directly
with officers to explore the range of
different funding opportunities that are
available to them of which still might
be won
so we've got grants officers we've got
funding officers and across the council
we've got proactive people who can help
them whether it's for environmental
improvements and they can speak to one
of cass's team or across the council and
your community's offices would be able
to facilitate those conversations into
other parts of the organization so the
key thing for ward councillors i think
is to encourage that aspiration
and then hand through to to officers who
can advise whether civ is the most
appropriate route or whether actually
there are better or more more relevant
funding mechanisms available to them
thank you tom thank you chair
thank you
right um we're now moving into debate um
baby members do any of you wish to make
any further comments council halt
it sort of follows on from what
discussion just proves he held but
i think the engagement of members is is
crucial in this and we've discussed it
before i think in cabinet about how we
feel that members across the district
aren't pushing and promoting sillas in
the way that we'd hoped um i just wonder
whether a report
could be done tom where it shows ward by
ward
what civil expenditure is still
expensive has been spent within those
wards against the income
and what sort of projects have been
actually carried out historically
because i'm not sure members all members
has been alluded to really understand
what sill can be used for to show
illustrations of what has been done
and also following on from that
boards that perhaps don't think they
have a lot of income from seal don't
really understand they can dip into the
bigger
pocket as well so
i think there's a lot more work that we
can do as a cabinet a lot more work we
can do as an authority to promote still
within our district and get our members
to engage in the process
thank you council hall council arthur
did you want to
well only just to say that every time we
present one of these reports we include
appendix a
which gives you a full history
of all of the sill awards
with all due respect i think we've got
to do more and promote it and i think we
should be sending out direct emails to
our members
promoting sil pushing sil
and trying to get
our parishes to engage
i'm aware of projects in my awards where
they haven't approached facile money and
i'm sure they could have qualified and
you push them as a member but i think
tom mentioned parish clerks as well it's
it's
there's a lot more work we could do a
lot more work and i think we need to do
it as an organization
yeah i i tend to agree i think um we do
need to have another communications push
with all members and with all parish
clerks so that um equally
they can
make the efforts from from both sides so
if if the paris clerk is is not um
as forthcoming perhaps in uh
or proactive in coming forward with
still applications and members can push
and vice versa if members are not um
pushing it as much as they they altered
and the parish class can and then get on
to the members so it needs to we need to
have that communication with both sides
and and get them together council
malvisi
um both you and councillor holt make
very good points but if tom can correct
me there was a time when you did pull
together
um parish clerks and ward members
and there was i mean i went to build
this term for one meeting and then there
was an another one
somewhere i think pinewood um
so
we were doing something i think it's
just sort of fallen off
off the radar at the moment
yeah tom
if it would be helpful yes um since the
introduction of still in 2016 there have
been a number of
community liaison events
whereby the council council officers
have um
both through the general
parish and town council liaison meetings
where seal officers have been i think
four times to those
but there have also been separate
bespoke meetings put on for
members of the community there have also
been some funding events that the
council has put on through its
communities team whereby seal has been
one of the mechanisms available
alongside our community grants alongside
the skills and expertise of our external
funding officer so there have been
um
there hasn't been anything over the last
18 months in terms of um face-to-face
and those kind of things clearly for
obvious obvious reasons so i think it
probably would be timely
to
perhaps reorganize and know that there
are conversations about
organizing
town and parish liaison meetings
but it might well be that i have a
conversation
with a new um assistant director for um
communities and wellbeing who's who's
here today um i have a conversation with
him about whether there's something the
communities team may wish to put on as a
kind of um
i don't know reinvigoration of the
opportunities that are out there to
build aspiration and confidence that
people should
take forward the projects and not
do that kind of self-censoring
self-limiting thing of thinking well
we're in a little old village there
won't be money out there available for
us therefore we'll dampen down our own
enthusiasm for xyz projects
thank you tom
um
mid suffolk members do you have anything
you wish to contribute to the debate at
this stage castle richardson
thank you chair it was just a comment
based on something that tom barker just
said which i absolutely agree with
in terms of the interlink between sil
and communities wellbeing and just given
what um is in the mid suffolk report i
thought it was kind of worth making this
this um kind of point that given the um
strategies that we now have in place
whether that's the leisure um physical
activity and sports strategy or the
well-being strategies actually seal
money can be a key enabler for some of
the things that are in there so within
mid-suffolk we have the the wheeled
sports facility in wrecking hall and the
upgrades to debenham community center
that can help um well that will enable
it to be used as sort of a multi-purpose
venue so i think there's a really
important interlink into what we can
deliver within planning and some of the
other areas of the council i think
that's a really important point that i
just want to emphasize thank you chair
thank you councillor
castleburn
thank you chairman just
comment on the um
the parish council liaison meetings that
we hold
um
we have traditionally of course uh had
face-to-face meetings for those and
um my experience the attendance has been
uh limited because of the difficulties
that a lot of parish councillors
experience in in getting to daytime
daytime meetings
it just occurs to me that uh with the
experience of the last 18 months
carrying out
virtual meetings
we are likely to reach many more um many
more councillors if we were to uh
approach approach um our liaison with
them uh
for this particular issue we're talking
about today if we were to approach that
on a virtual basis rather than a
face-to-face meeting anyway so i would i
would just suggest that that was
something worth exploring rather than um
sticking to uh our cell training as
being restricted to
face-to-face
liaison meetings thank you
thank you councillor
any other
comments from anyone
in which case then i'll ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
you
chair that is eight eight votes four for
uh paper recommendations and six votes
for for mid-suffolk recommendations so
they're both unanimous
thank you henry
right uh the next item is for
mid-suffolk members only and so
councilor brewster will therefore take
the chair for this item and they'll now
be a short break to allow officers to be
seated and for baber members to depart
um
the item is mca oblique 21 oblique 23
gateway 14 limited guarantee of public
infrastructure works until adoption
i will now invite the mid-southern
cabinet member for assets and
investments to introduce the report
councillor gould please
thank you very much uh chair and i'm i'm
pleased to present this report to the
cabinet which takes a gateway 14 limited
into the delivery phase of the of the
development with the creation of the
business part framework and
infrastructure including necessary
off-site public works
to improve highways and
utilities
the report recommends that the council
acts as guarantor for public works be
delivered by gateway 14 under agreements
with statutory bodies
this is the most efficient approach
which mitigates the council's borrowing
requirements whilst providing the
necessary
security to ensure that the off-site
works and improvements are completed
you will see from the report that this
proposal sits within the council's
powers
and meets the test of reasonableness
gateway 14 is a huge opportunity for our
district
and is set to deliver thousands of jobs
and grow the economy of mid-suffolk by
delivering approximately 2.5 2.4 million
square feet of sustainable business
accommodation
in a high quality business park
environment
which also enhances biodiversity
i'm genuinely excited to see work start
on site in the near future and for this
business park
to take shape and deliver for our
district thank you very much chad
a proposer and a seconder
well i clearly propose the uh
recommended thank you sorry that's right
and a second to please
councillor hattingham thank you
fine um questions from any members
present
in the cabinet
no
we'll go to other members then
councillor keith scarf
sorry councillor keith wellum
he's not here
[Laughter]
thank you uh thank you chairman
um
this matter is obviously a decision for
cabinet however could i ask that local
members are kept better informed of
discussions
and decisions around gateway 14.
you will recall
many months ago
i was
told by the leader that there would be
meetings which would involve local
councillors
and board members and the like
no such meeting has yet been arranged
despite me chasing the the leader for
dates for a meeting so uh it's it's
unfortunate but not better informed um
because there are meetings going ahead
um representatives of stonewalker eco
futures group and the creating residents
association have had a meeting with
representatives of gateway 14 and i have
a meeting this evening to be briefed by
them about
about what's going on now that's the
wrong way
i should not be asking
stone market eco futures group accreting
residents association to let me know
what's going on at mid-suffolk so can we
please have
much much better um
a much bit much much more information to
local members please
thank you uh councilwoman uh
what would certainly do is
revisit the the leader's commitment
on this uh to remind myself what that is
and i'll certainly talk to her about uh
what what what was promised and what we
ought to be delivering in terms of local
member
consultation i don't know whether the
assistant director has anything to add
in terms of briefing arrangements beyond
that
thank you councillor and i'm always
happy to talk to all counsellors around
projects that we're
delivering and i know we have a meeting
later this week and to talk about
gateway 14 further and so but
equally happy to meet with you after
this meeting and help brief you for the
parish council this meet this evening if
that would be helpful
councillor william thank you um
it seems that members need to know what
questions they need to ask
before they can ask them but we don't
know what those questions are because we
don't actually know what's going on we
need to be briefed and have an
opportunity for discussion not wait
until we've we've heard that something
has already taken place
um and if i may respond to councillor
gould
i mean i know the commitment that the
leader made but even if she had not made
that commitment i still think
that parish councils i mean
one of one of the councils that i
represent
that their boundary is about 50 yards
48 meters away from the the site and
they've had no information whatsoever
whatsoever
so if my previous answers sounded overly
cautious uh i
i'd absolutely take your point about
councillors understanding what is
a project of such enormous advantage and
benefit
to mid-suffolk that local councillors
ought to
have a have an understanding uh
if not an opportunity to contribute to
the development of that uh opportunity
so it's certainly our talk with the
assistant director about what briefing
arrangements we might make
in order to improve the flow
so say apologies my initial answer
sounded somewhat defensive because
there's absolutely no need
to be so
thank you
um
i mean i think on the bulk of the paper
it is clear that this is a sensible way
ahead so
questions really revolve around the
thought of um
clearly
it's good to be getting on with the with
things like the highways work
to enable development the risk is
how certain is the development
how interested our people to to move
ahead
and i sort of always contrast this with
with um
port one uh at great bacon which i know
somewhat better where
uh buildings are going up but the
highways work hasn't been done you know
there are temporary entrances
in place and very large sheds are
appearing
and where i certainly some years ago was
told more or less the list of people who
were waiting to move into the buildings
once they were up
i don't get the same feeling at gateway
14.
sorry yes there is a question um
sorry about that but uh
please you have to understand where i'm
coming from to an extent
the the
the point really is
um basically i don't expect you to quote
names and things but is there strong
interest are you taking this decision on
the basis that there are people waiting
to occupy the buildings we're trying to
build so the thing clearly has a future
he's clearly moving ahead or are we
still peddling a
big green field that we hope people will
be interested in
thanks i'll um
i think there's every reason for
confidence to be growing rather than uh
diminishing in in terms of this and
there are obviously you yourself refer
to the constraints of discussing these
things within uh open session or even
outside uh the rules of commercial
confidentiality but i don't know i'll
see if we can ask the assistant director
there's something some comfort that she
can bring
in terms of the response that is being
got the interest that's been expressed
in the site
thank you councillor um yes we do have a
list of interested parties for the site
and we've particularly seen interest in
the site increase since the freeport
announcement and so we're very confident
that there will be
strong demand for this site and
continued strong demand
and as soon as we start the commencement
of the development works on site we see
that this interest will um will increase
further
so we are confident that there's
interest in the site and there's demand
there are a number of companies that
we're in quite detailed discussions with
but one of the key aspects that these
companies are are keen to to determine
is is the timeline and so the detailed
work that we're doing now in terms of
the infrastructure works and timetable
for delivery of those works will help us
in terms of the discussions we're having
with occupiers because they want to know
um when they would be able to occupy
their building
and that feeds into
the delivery of the road and the
utilities etc on site but but yes we are
confident that there is strong interest
out there
and this
scheme will be very successful moving
forward
thank you
are you satisfied there
cancerfield
as much as one can ever be satisfied not
being able to foretell the future
thank you just remind you if we do need
to go into closed session we'll be going
into debate
um
please don't
pick that up we'll go into closed
session if you wish to at the later
stage
uh so i will now open the item up for
debate
councillor richardson
thank you chair just um wanted to make a
very brief uh comment because i well
in effect all i'm going to say is that i
completely agree with everything that
council gold said um in his introduction
around the importance of this work and
about moving into the delivery phase
that we do this in a timely manner and i
just wanted to reiterate that because i
think it's it's exceptionally important
so i shall definitely be voting in favor
of the recommendation
and again i think that that does seem to
be the most reasonable and logical way
forward so i think that's absolutely
what we should be doing thank you chair
counselor
it's not so much part of the debate it's
a question really i should have asked as
a sort of supplementary to counselor
phil's question
and my question would be i think to the
assistant director is does she have a
sense that there is
um
more interest being shown than we have
capacity to accommodate
be reassuring
and
so i think that's quite a difficult uh
question to answer but i think um when
we looked at the development um
uh
delivery live
time of this uh development um
originally last february when we
appointed the um
uh the managing uh sorry the development
managers to the scheme we were
anticipating a 10-year delivery period
since the freeport
designation has been announced we're
starting to consider whether actually
that may be more of a sort of five-year
period
so i think indirectly that probably does
answer your question to a degree in that
if we think we can deliver the scheme in
a much shorter period that suggests that
there's more interest than we had
originally anticipated and that
potentially there will be parties who
um
more parties who are interested in
taking space there than we can
ultimately uh deliver having said that
it is 150 odd acres and therefore in
this initial period i don't think there
will be any issues about not be being
able to accommodate people on site but
um certainly there is a strong degree of
interest and as we get nearer to the end
of that uh delivery period i suspect
there may be some occupiers who are
we're not able to accommodate on site
and will need to look at where else
within the district we can accommodate
those uses
anyone else wish to speak
no
okay
i mean to me the recommendation sounds a
very common sense way of approaching uh
this item really
um
so i will
now ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote please
thank you chan the vote is now in
progress on your app
chair that is six votes for and that's
unanimous
thank you very much
having done that item is there any wish
to go into the closed session
that item will be deleted off the agenda
thank you very much
so
the date and the time of the next
meeting
is
monday the 4th of november
at 10 30 a.m
and so we reached the close of the
meeting and i thank you all very much
for your attendance
and call the meeting till close thank
you
you